VERY SHORTLY AFTER THE ELECTION
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN RECOGNIZED
THAT THEY HAD LIKELY LOST THE
ELECTION AND THEY INFORMED
DONALD TRUMP OF THAT FACT.
EVEN BEFORE THE NETWORKS CALLED
THE RACE FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN ON
NOVEMBER 7th, HIS CHANCES OF
PULLING OUT A VICTORY WERE
VIRTUALLY NONEXISTENT AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP KNEW IT.
>> DO YOU KNOW IF ANYBODY EVER
TOLD THE PRESIDENT THAT HE HAD
LOST AND THAT THERE WASN'T A
CHANCE OF HIM WINNING?
>> THE -- I KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT WHEN THE NETWORKS
CALLED IT, OF COURSE, HE WAS
INFORMED ABOUT THE NETWORK
DECISION.
THAT AFTERNOON AT SOME POINT
MYSELF AND A HANDFUL OF OTHER
FOLKS WENT OVER AND SAT DOWN
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
COMMUNICATED THAT THE ODDS OF US
PREVAILING AND LEGAL CHALLENGES
WERE VERY SMALL.
>> YOU KNOW, AFTER THE ELECTION
AS OF NOVEMBER 7th, IN YOUR
JUDGMENT, WHAT WERE THE CHANCES
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP WINNING THE
ELECTION?
>> AFTER THAT POINT?
>> YES.
>> NONE.
AT TIMES PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACKNOWLEDGED THE REALITY OF HIS
LOSS.
ALTHOUGH HE PUBLICLY CLAIMED
THAT HE HAD WON THE ELECTION,
PRIVATELY HE ADMITTED THAT JOE
BIDEN WOULD TAKE OVER AS
PRESIDENT.
HERE'S A FEW EXAMPLES OF THAT.
>> SO WE'RE IN THE OVAL AND
THERE'S A DISCUSSION GOING ON
AND THE PRESIDENT SAYS, I
THINK -- IT COULD HAVE BEEN
POMPEO BUT SAYS WORDS TO THE
EFFECT OF, YEAH, WE LOST, WE
NEED TO LET THAT ISSUE GO TO THE
NEXT GUY, MEANING PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
>> I REMEMBER MAYBE A WEEK AFTER
THE ELECTION WAS CALLED, I
POPPED INTO THE OVAL JUST TO
LIKE GIVE THE PRESIDENT THE
HEADLINES AND SEE HOW HE WAS
DOING AND HE WAS LOOKING AT THE
TV AND SAID, CAN YOU BELIEVE I
LOST TO THIS F'ing GUY.
>> MARC RAISED IT WITH ME ON THE
18th.
DRIVING BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
SAID DOES THE PRESIDENT REALLY
THINK HE LOST, AND HE SAID, A
LOT OF TIMES HE'LL TELL ME THAT
HE LOST BUT HE WANTS TO KEEP
FIGHTING IT.
HE THINKS THERE MIGHT BE ENOUGH
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION BUT
PRETTY MUCH ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
HE'S LOST.
>> KNOWING THAT HE HAD LOST AND
THAT HE HAD ONLY WEEKS LEFT IN
OFFICE, PRESIDENT TRUMP RUSHED
TO COMPLETE HIS UNFINISHED
BUSINESS.
ONE KEY EXAMPLE IS THIS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISSUED AN ORDER
FOR LARGE-SCALE U.S. TROOP
WITHDRAWALS.
HE DISREGARDED CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CONSEQUENCES FOR FRAGILE
GOVERNMENTS ON THE FRONT LINES
OF THE FIGHT AGAINST ISIS AND AL
QAEDA TERRORISTS.
KNOWING HE WAS LEAVING OFFICE,
HE ACTED IMMEDIATELY AND SIGNED
THIS ORDER ON NOVEMBER 11th
WHICH WOULD HAVE REQUIRED THE
IMMEDIATE WITHDRAWAL OF TROOPS
FROM SOMALIA AND AFGHANISTAN ALL
TO BE COMPLETE BEFORE THE BIDEN
INAUGURATION ON JANUARY 20th.
AS YOU WATCH THESE CLIPS RECALL
THAT GENERAL KEITH KELLOGG WAS
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER TO
THE VICE PRESIDENT AND HAD
SERVED AS CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND GENERAL
MILLEY WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF AT THE
PENTAGON.
>> ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH A MEMO
THAT THE PRESIDENT REPORTEDLY
SIGNED ON NOVEMBER 11th, 2020
ORDERING THAT TROOPS BE
WITHDRAWN FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
SOMALIA.
>> YES.
>> SO, I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE
SEEN SOME THINGS WHERE THIS MEMO
OR SOMETHING FROM JOHNNY McATEE
TO DOUGLAS McGREGOR, IT SAYS,
HERE'S YOUR TASK TO GET U.S.
FORCES OUT OF -- OUT OF SOMALIA,
GET U.S. FORCES OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
>> WHEN YOU FIRST INTERVIEWED
AND MET COLONEL DOUGLAS
McGREGOR, IS IT FAIR TO SAY YOU
DISCUSSED THIS DECISION OF
WITHDRAWING FROM SOMALIA AND
AFGHANISTAN?
>> CORRECT.
>> YEAH, I'M SURE THAT WAS PART
OF IT, YEAH.
>> AND THAT WAS -- THE POSITION
THAT HE WAS TAKING OVER THERE
WAS SENIOR ADVISER TO THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> YES.
>> SO ON THAT SAME DAY, JUST SO
I'M CLEAR, HE RESPONDED BACK TO
YOU THAT THEY, MEANING DOD
LEADERSHIP WAS NOT GOING TO
DO -- TAKE ANY OF THOSE STEPS
WITHOUT AN ORDER?
>> WITHOUT A DIRECTIVE, YEAH.
>> I EXPLAINED IN LANGUAGE THAT
SHOULD BE IN THE ORDER WHILE I
WAS IN THE MEETING WITH McENTEE
AND THIS WAS MY ANSWER TO HIM, I
SAID, IF YOU WANT THIS TO HAPPEN
OR THE PRESIDENT WANTS THIS TO
HAPPEN, HE'S GOT TO WRITE AN
ORDER.
>> SO YOU NEVER WROTE IT DOWN IN
ANY CAPACITY.
>> I SKETCHED ON A PIECE OF
PAPER FOR HIM SOME KEY
STATEMENTS, YOU KNOW, THE
PRESIDENT DIRECTS.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS -- WHAT'S THE
RIGHT WORD -- BOILERPLATE
LANGUAGE.
>> WHO IN THE OFFICE DRAFTED THE
ORDER?
>> IT WAS MYSELF AND ONE OF MY
ASSISTANTS.
>> McENTEE DULY TYPES IT UP,
BRINGS IT INTO THE PRESIDENT AND
THE PRESIDENT SIGNS IT.
>> WAS IT BY AUTO PEN OR THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF SIGNING IT?
>> IT WAS THE PRESIDENT.
>> AND WHO OBTAINED THAT
SIGNATURE?
>> I DID.
>> IT IS ODD, IT IS NONSTANDARD.
IT IS POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS, I
PERSONALLY THOUGHT IT WAS
MILITARILY NOT FEASIBLE, NOR
WISE.
>> AND I PROCEEDED TO TELL THE
PPO AND PROCEEDED TO TELL
MACGREGOR THAT IF I EVER SAW
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, UM, I WOULD
DO SOMETHING PHYSICAL BECAUSE I
FELT THAT WAS WAS A TREMENDOUS
DISSERVICE TO THE NATION AND, BY
THE WAY, THAT WAS A VERY, VERY
CONTESTED ISSUE.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO DID NOT
AGREE WITH GETTING OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
I APPRECIATE THEIR CONCERN AND
IMMEDIATE DEPARTURE THAT THAT
MEMO SAID WOULD HAVE BEEN A
CATASTROPHIC -- IT'S THE SAME
THING FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A DEBACLE.
>> KEEP IN MIND, THE ORDER WAS
FOR AN IMMEDIATE WITHDRAWAL.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN CATASTROPHIC
AND YET PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED
THE ORDER.
THESE ARE THE HIGHLY
CONSEQUENTIAL ACTIONS OF A
PRESIDENT WHO KNOWS HIS TERM
WILL SHORTLY END.
AT THE SAME TIME PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACKNOWLEDGED PIRATELY HE LOST
THE ELECTION HE WAS HEARING
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF FRAUD
OR IRREGULARITIES SUFFICIENT TO
CHANGE THE OUTCOME.
>> I REMEMBER, UM, A CALL WITH
MR. MEADOWS WHERE MR. MEADOWS
WAS ASKING ME WHAT I WAS FINDING
AND IF I WAS FINDING ANYTHING
AND I REMEMBER SHARING WITH HIM
THAT WE WEREN'T FINDING ANYTHING
THAT WOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO
CHANGE THE RESULTS IN ANY OF THE
KEY STATES.
>> WHEN WAS THAT CONVERSATION?
>> PROBABLY IN NOVEMBER, MID TO
LATE NOVEMBER.
I THINK IT WAS BEFORE MY CHILD
WAS BORN.
>> AND WHAT WAS MR. MEADOWS'
REACTION TO THAT INFORMATION?
>> I BELIEVE THE WORDS HE USED
WERE SO THERE'S NO THERE THERE.
>> IT WOULD BE OUR JOB TO TRACK
IT DOWN AND COME UP DRY BECAUSE
THE ALLEGATION DIDN'T PROVE TO
BE TRUE AND WE'D HAVE TO, YOU
KNOW, RELAY THE NEWS THAT, YEAH,
THAT TIP THAT SOMEONE TOLD YOU
ABOUT THOSE VOTES OR THAT FRAUD
OR, YOU KNOW, NOTHING CAME OF
IT.
IT WOULD BE OUR JOB AS, YOU
KNOW, TRUTH TELLING AND, YOU
KNOW, NOT A FUN JOB TO BE, YOU
KNOW -- IT'S AN EASIER JOB TO BE
TELLING THE PRESIDENT ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, WILD ALLEGATIONS, IT'S A
HARDER JOB TO TELL HIM ON THE
BACK END, YEAH, THAT WAS THE
TRUTH.
>> WHAT WAS GENERALLY DISCUSSED
ON THAT TOPIC WAS WHETHER THE
FRAUD, ABUSE OR IRREGULARITIES
IF AGGREGATED AND READ MOST
FAVORABLY TO THE CAMPAIGN WOULD
BE OUTCOME DETERMINATIVE AND I
THINK EVERYONE'S ASSESSMENT IN
THE ROOM AT LEAST AMONG THE
STAFF, MARC SHORT, MYSELF AND
GREG JACOB WAS IT WAS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO BE OUTCOME
DETERMINATIVE.
>> LOOK, IT'S THE RIGHT OF ANY
CANDIDATE TO LITIGATE GENUINE
ELECTION DISPUTES.
NOBODY ARGUES THAT BUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S LITIGATION WAS
COMPLETELY UNSUCCESSFUL.
AND OUR PAST HEARINGS WE TOLD
YOU THE COMMITTEE HAD IDENTIFIED
A TOTAL OF 62 ELECTION LAWSUITS
FILED BY THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
ITS ALLIES BETWEEN NOVEMBER 4th
AND JANUARY 6th OF 2021.
THOSE CASES RESULTED IN 61
LOSSES AND ONLY A SINGLE VICTORY
WHICH DID NOT AFFECT THE OUTCOME
FOR ANY CANDIDATE.
THE CLAIMS WERE NOT SUPPORTED BY
ANY SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE OF FRAUD
OR IRREGULARITIES.
IN FACT, THEY WERE BASELESS AS
JUDGES REPEATEDLY RECOGNIZED.
IN NONE OF THESE 62 CASES WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABLE TO
ESTABLISH ANY VIABLE CLAIMS OF
ELECTION FRAUD SUFFICIENT TO
OVERTURN THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION.
IN THOSE HEARINGS WE SHARED WITH
YOU THE WORDS USED BY JUDGES
AROUND THE COUNTRY IN REJECTING
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN'S CLAIMS.
IT'S STRONG LANGUAGE CRITICIZING
THE LACK OF EVIDENTIARY SUPPORT
FOR THE CLAIMS OF ELECTION FRAUD
IN THOSE LAWSUIT, FOR EXAMPLE, A
FEDERAL APPEALS COURT IN
PENNSYLVANIA WROTE, QUOTE,
CHARGES REQUIRE SPECIFIC
ALLEGATIONS AND PROOF.
WE HAVE NEITHER HERE.
A FEDERAL JUDGE IN WISCONSIN
WROTE, QUOTE, THE COURT HAS
ALLOWED THE FORMER PRESIDENT THE
CHANCE TO MAKE HIS CASE, AND HE
HAS LOST ON THE MERITS.
ANOTHER JUDGE IN MICHIGAN CALLED
THE CLAIM, QUOTE, NOTHING BUT
SPECULATION AND CONJECTURE THAT
VOTES FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP WERE
DESTROYED, DISCARDED OR SWITCHED
TO VOTES FOR VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
A FEDERAL JUDGE IN MICHIGAN
SANCTIONED NINE ATTORNEYS
INCLUDING SIDNEY POWELL FOR
MAKING FRIVOLOUS ALLEGATIONS IN
AN ELECTION FRAUD CASE
DESCRIBING THE CASE AS A
HISTORIC AND PROFOUND ABUSE OF
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS.
RECENTLY A GROUP OF
DISTINGUISHED REPUBLICAN
ELECTION LAWYER, FORMER JUDGES
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS ISSUED A
REPORT CONFIRMING THE FINDINGS
OF THE COURTS.
IN THEIR REPORT ENTITLED LOST,
NOT STOLEN, THESE PROMINENT
REPUBLICANS ANALYZED EACH
ELECTION CHALLENGE AND CONCLUDED
THIS, DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS HAVE FAILED TO
PRESENT EVIDENCE OF FRAUD OR
INACCURATE RESULTS SIGNIFICANT
ENOUGH TO INVALIDATE THE RESULTS
OF THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
ON DECEMBER 11th TRUMP'S ALLIES
LOST A LAWSUIT IN THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT THAT HE REGARDED
AS HIS LAST CHANCE AT SUCCESS IN
THE COURTS.
A NEWLY OBTAINED SECRET SERVICE
MESSAGE FROM THAT DAY SHOWS HOW
ANGRY PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ABOUT
THE OUTCOME, QUOTE, JUST FYI,
POTUS IS PISSED.
BREAKING NEWS, SUPREME COURT
DENIED HIS LAWSUIT.
HE IS LIVID NOW.
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, AN AIDE TO
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS WAS
PRESENT FOR THAT CONVERSATION
AND DESCRIBED IT IN THIS WAY.
>> THIS IS THE DAY THAT THE
SUPREME COURT HAD REJECTED THAT
CASE.
WE WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
RESIDENCE AT A CHRISTMAS
RECEPTION.
AND AS WE WERE WALKING BACK FROM
THE CHRISTMAS RECEPTION THAT
EVENING, THE PRESIDENT WAS
WALKING OUT OF THE OVAL OFFICE.
WE CROSSED PATHS IN THE ROSE
GARDEN COLONNADE.
THE PRESIDENT WAS FIRED UP ABOUT
THE SUPREME COURT DECISION AND
SO, YOU KNOW, I WAS STANDING
NEXT TO MR. MEADOWS, I STEPPED
BACK SO I WAS PROBABLY TWO,
THREE FEET CATTY-CORNER OR
DIAGONAL FROM HIM.
THE PRESIDENT JUST RAGING ABOUT
THE DECISION AND HOW IT'S WRONG
AND WHY DIDN'T WE MAKE MORE
CALLS AND JUST HIS TYPICAL
ANGER, OUTBURSTS AT THIS
DECISION AND THE PRESIDENT SAID,
HE -- SO HE HAD SAID SOMETHING
TO THE EFFECT OF, I DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW WE LOST, MARK.
THIS IS EMBARRASSING.
FIGURE IT OUT.
WE NEED TO FIGURE IT OUT.
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW WE
LOST.
>> OUR COUNTRY IS A COUNTRY OF
LAWS WHERE EVERY PERSON
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT MUST
FOLLOW THE LAW AND RESPECT THE
JUDGMENT OF OUR COURTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CLOSEST
ADVISERS HELD THAT VIEW BOTH
THEN AND NOW.
>> WELL, DO YOU BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD ABIDE BY THE
RULINGS OF THE COURTS?
>> OH, YES, WE SHOULD ALL COMPLY
WITH THE LAW AT ALL TIMES TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY.
EVERY ONE OF US.
>> SO ONCE THE COURTS HAD RULED
AND THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE HAD
MET, THE ELECTION WAS OVER IN
YOUR VIEW?
>> YES, I THINK I'VE SAID
PREVIOUSLY THAT WHEN THE VICE
PRESIDENT MADE THE CERTIFICATION
AND THE LITIGATION WAS COMPLETE,
IT WAS COMPLETE.
>> WHEN THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
MET ON THE 14th?
>> YES, AS OF DECEMBER 14th, IS
THAT RIGHT?
I THINK THAT'S THE RIGHT DATE,
YES.
>> I ASSUME, PAT, YOU WOULD
AGREE THE PRESIDENT IS OBLIGATED
TO ABIDE BY THE RULINGS OF THE
COURTS?
>> OF COURSE.
>> AND I ASSUME YOU ALSO --
>> EVERYBODY IS OBLIGATED TO
ABIDE BY THE RULINGS OF THE
COURTS.
>> AND I ASSUME YOU ALSO WOULD
AGREE THE PRESIDENT HAS A
PARTICULAR OBLIGATION TO TAKE
CARE THAT THE LAWS BE FAITHFULLY
EXECUTED?
>> THAT IS
ONE OF THE OBLIGATIONS, CORRECT.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
IS OBLIGATED TO ABIDE BY THE
RULINGS OF THE COURT?
>> I DO.
>> BY MID DECEMBER OF 2020,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SENIOR STAFF
WERE ATTEMPTING TO PERSUADE HIM
TO CONCEDE THE ELECTION OUTCOME.
>> BUT IF YOUR QUESTION IS DID I
BELIEVE HE SHOULD CONCEDE THE
ELECTION AT A POINT IN TIME,
YES, I DID.
>> DECEMBER 14th WAS THE DAY THE
STATE CERTIFIED THE VOTES AND
SENT THEM TO CONGRESS.
IN MY VIEW THAT WAS THE END OF
THE MATTER.
I DIDN'T SEE -- I THOUGHT THIS
WOULD LEAD INEXPLORABLELY TO A
NEW ADMINISTRATION.
>> I TOLD HIM MY PERSONAL
VIEWPOINT WAS THAT THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE HAD MET, WHICH IS THE
SYSTEM THAT OUR COUNTRY IS SET
UNDER TO ELECT A PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT, AND I BELIEVED
AT THAT POINT THAT THE MEANS FOR
HIM TO PURSUE LITIGATION WAS
PROBABLY CLOSED.
>> AND DO YOU RECALL WHAT HIS
RESPONSE, IF ANY WAS?
>> HE DISAGREED.
>> SECRETARY OF LABOR, GENE
SCALIA, THE SON OF LATE JUSTICE
SCALIA VISITED PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN MID DECEMBER AND EXPLAINED
THE SITUATION CLEARLY.
>> AND SO I HAD PUT A CALL INTO
THE PRESIDENT, I MIGHT HAVE
CALLED ON THE 13th.
WE SPOKE, I BELIEVE, ON THE
14th, IN WHICH I CONVEYED TO HIM
THAT I THOUGHT THAT IT WAS TIME
FOR HIM TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD PREVAILED IN
THE ELECTION.
BUT I COMMUNICATED TO THE
PRESIDENT THAT WHEN THAT LEGAL
PROCESS IS EXHAUSTED AND WHEN
THE ELECTORS HAVE VOTED THAT
THAT'S THE POINT AT WHICH THAT
OUTCOME NEEDS TO BE EXPECTED.
I TOLD HIM THAT I DID BELIEVE,
YES, THAT ONCE THOSE LEGAL
PROCESSES WERE RUN, IF FRAUD HAD
NOT BEEN ESTABLISHED, THAT HAD
AFFECTED THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION THEN UNFORTUNATELY I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT HAD TO BE DONE
WAS CONCEDE THE OUTCOME.
>> NOT ONLY DID THE COURTS
REJECT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FRAUD
AND OTHER ALLEGATIONS, HIS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
APPOINTEES, INCLUDING JEFFREY
ROSEN AND RICHARD DONOGHUE DID
AS WELL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP KNEW THE TRUTH.
HE HEARD WHAT ALL HIS EXPERTS
AND SENIOR STAFF WERE TELLING
HIM.
HE KNEW HE HAD LOST THE ELECTION
BUT HE MADE THE DELIBERATE
CHOICE TO IGNORE THE COURTS, TO
IGNORE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
TO IGNORE HIS CAMPAIGN
LEADERSHIP, TO IGNORE SENIOR
ADVISERS AND TO PURSUE A
COMPLETELY UNLAWFUL EFFORT TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
HIS INTENT WAS PLAIN.
IGNORE THE RULE OF LAW AND STAY
IN POWER.
MR. CHAIRMAN, I YIELD BACK.